Let us try to understand the
format of the data handed
to us in the CSV files.
Grayscale images are represented
as a matrix of pixel intensity
values that range
from zero to one.
The intensity value zero
corresponds to the absence
of color, or black, and the
value one corresponds to white.
For 8 bits per pixel images,
we have 256 color levels
ranging from zero to one.
For instance, if we have the
following grayscale image,
the pixel information
can be translated
to a matrix of values
between zero and one.
It is exactly this matrix that
we are given in our datasets.
In other words, the
datasets contain a table
of values between zero and one.
And the number of
columns corresponds
to the width of the image,
whereas the number of rows
corresponds to the
height of the image.
In this example, the
resolution is 7 by 7 pixels.
We have to be careful when
reading the dataset in R.
We need to make
sure that R reads
in the matrix appropriately.
Until now in this
class, our datasets
were structured in a way where
the rows refer to observations
and the columns
refer to variables.
But this is not the case
for the intensity matrix.
So keep in mind that we
need to do some maneuvering
to make sure that R recognizes
the data as a matrix.
Grayscale image segmentation
can be done by clustering pixels
according to their
intensity values.
So we can think of our
clustering algorithm
as trying to divide the
spectrum of intensity values
from zero to one into
intervals, or clusters.
For instance, the red
cluster corresponds
to the darkest shades, and the
green cluster to the lightest.
Now, what should the input be
to the clustering algorithm?
Well, our observations
should be all of the 7
by 7 intensity values.
Hence, we should
have 49 observations.
And we only have
one variable, which
is the pixel intensity value.
So in other words, the input
to the clustering algorithm
should be a vector containing 49
elements, or intensity values.
But what we have
is a 7 by 7 matrix.
A crucial step before
feeding the intensity
values to the clustering
algorithm is morphing our data.
We should modify
the matrix structure
and lump all the intensity
values into a single vector.
We will see that
we can do this in R
using the as.vector function.
Now, once we have the
vector, we can simply
feed it into the
clustering algorithm
and assign each element in
the vector to a cluster.
Let us first use
hierarchical clustering
since we are familiar with it.
The first step is to calculate
the distance matrix, which
computes the pairwise
distances among the elements
of the intensity vector.
How many such distances
do we need to calculate?
Well, for each element
in the intensity vector,
we need to calculate its
distance from the other 48
elements.
So this makes 48
calculations per element.
And we have 49 such elements
in the intensity vector.
In total, we should compute 49
times 48 pairwise distances.
But due to symmetry, we really
need to calculate half of them.
So the number of pairwise
distance calculations is
actually (49*48)/2.
In general, if we call the
size of the intensity vector n,
then we need to compute
n*(n-1)/2 pairwise distances
and store them in
the distance matrix.
Now we should be
ready to go to R.
I already navigated
to the directory
where we saved the
flower.csv file, which
contains the matrix of pixel
intensities of a flower image.
Let us read in the matrix
and save it to a data frame
and call it flower, then
use the read.csv function
to instruct R to read
in the flower dataset.
And then we have to
explicitly mention
that we have no
headers in the CSV file
because it only contains a
matrix of intensity values.
So we're going to
type header=FALSE.
Note that the
default in R assumes
that the first row in the
dataset is the header.
So if we didn't specify that we
have no headers in this case,
we would have lost
the information
from the first row of the
pixel intensity matrix.
Now let us look at the structure
of the flower data frame.
We realize that the
way the data is stored
does not reflect that this is
a matrix of intensity values.
Actually, R treats the rows as
observations and the columns
as variables.
Let's try to change the
data type to a matrix
by using the as.matrix function.
So let's define our
variable flowerMatrix
and then use the
as.matrix function, which
takes as an input the
flower data frame.
And now if we look at the
structure of the flower matrix,
we realize that we have
50 rows and 50 columns.
What this suggests is that
the resolution of the image
is 50 pixels in width
and 50 pixels in height.
This is actually a very,
very small picture.
I am very curious to see how
this image looks like, but lets
hold off now and do
our clustering first.
We do not want to be influenced
by how the image looks
like in our decision of
the numbers of clusters
we want to pick.
To perform any
type of clustering,
we saw earlier
that we would need
to convert the matrix
of pixel intensities
to a vector that contains all
the intensity values ranging
from zero to one.
And the clustering algorithm
divides the intensity spectrum,
the interval zero to one,
into these joint clusters
or intervals.
So let us define the
vector flowerVector,
and then now we're going to use
the function as.vector, which
takes as an input
the flowerMatrix.
And now if we look at the
structure of the flowerVector,
we realize that we have
2,500 numerical values, which
range between zero and one.
And this totally makes sense
because this reflects the 50
times 50 intensity values
that we had in our matrix.
Now you might be wondering
why we can't immediately
convert the data frame
flower to a vector.
Let's try to do this.
So let's go back to
our as.vector function
and then have the input
be the flower data
frame instead of
the flower matrix.
And then, let's name this
variable flowerVector2, simply
so that we don't overwrite
the flower vector.
And now let's look
at its structure.
It seems that R reads it exactly
like the flower data frame
and sees it as 50
observations and 50 variables.
So converting the data to a
matrix and then to the vector
is a crucial step.
Now we should be ready to start
our hierarchical clustering.
The first step is to create the
distance matrix, as you already
know, which in
this case computes
the difference between every two
intensity values in our flower
vector.
So let's type
distance=dist(flowerVector,
method="euclidean").
Now that we have
the distance, next
we will be computing the
hierarchical clusters.